[Music]
most people think Mitt Romney won the
debate last night this is even more
impressive given one of Romney's
physical tics look what we've done thank
you Jim
it's an honor to be here with you and I
appreciate the chance to be with the
president I'm pleased to be at the
University of Denver appreciate their
welcome the other thing we have to do to
save Medicare we have to have the
benefits high for those that are low
income I met a couple and Appleton
Wisconsin and they said we're thinking
of dropping our insurance we can't
afford it wrote and said what we did in
Massachusetts could be a model for the
nation and I agree that the Democratic
legislators in Massachusetts might have
given some advice I will keep America
strong and get America's middle class
working again thank you Jim
[Music]